course I began by asking him whether he
agreed with David Anderson the case
hasn't yet been made for the so-called
snoopers charter well he's also made the
case that the significant powers that
the police and the intelligence agencies
have are necessary including the
controversial pass for bulk access to
data and it's also concluded you can
have those powers and be consistent with
our human rights and protect and respect
our privacy and freedom of speech but if
you're going to do that the law has got
to be a lot clearer than it is today see
that the current legislation has done
very well it's lasted 15 years that
technology's moved on and various bits
and pieces have been added and there are
different powers and different bits of
legislation so I think he's quite right
to say actually why don't we start again
and revalidate those paths but the
important thing the really important
thing is the powers that the authorities
need to keep us safe he has said yes
they do need them what about the powers
to mine data which is at the heart of
the so-called snoopers charter to be
able to access what we look hot not
necessarily in terms of the detailed
information but our browser history if
you like well I personally still think
there's a good case to be made for
asking the Internet companies to retain
that data but of course only to access
it when you have a legal warrant and
which means justification for accessing
it and the so-called snoopers Charter
was examined it was taken back from
Parliament it was rewritten what David
Anderson is saying is that some of that
is necessary other parts of it if the
agencies think there is a case they've
got to make a stronger one
they have done so far well that's fair
enough if they really think it's
important they'll make that case do you
think they will I think for some of it
for looking at the browsing history with
a warrant where there is a suspect I
think there is a good case for that
whether it's necessary to have a power
to up for all the internet providers to
retain data on you perhaps that that
isn't necessary what they're going to do
legally with the the big companies are
the apples and the googles who are
introducing ever more elaborate
encryption services on offer to their
customers people who want to protect
them information makes it obviously
increasingly more difficult for security
agencies to access it understandably are
they're going to have to be new laws
compelling those companies to hand over
information well when I've talked to the
company's the line I've had from them is
that they want to be responsible
citizens they believe in good corporate
governance if there is a lawful warrant
presented properly to them and it's
clear though sir it is lawful for them
to hand over information for example
about a bit of our ring or terrorist
suspect then they would want to do so
what has worried them up till now is
some ambiguity about well are they
actually authorized to do that is there
a conflict between their duty if they're
based in the United States United States
law and the UK law so that needs to be
sorted out and David Anderson obviously
has looked at that and suggested some
ideas yeah he has said housing in this
report that there needs to be a culture
internationally of agreement how hard is
that going to be to achieve though I
think it will be it will be hard the
there's a lot of suspicion around the
companies are very worried about their
commercial reputations in the rest of
the world and then basically like China
if there seemed to be opening their
doors to United States or British
intelligence but that's not the
proposition the property
is that they should respond to legally
authorized warrants and I don't think
that should be too difficult but it will
all need to be when the temperature of
all of this has calmed down and Snowden
unfortunately has raised the temperature
and made the company's very nervous when
it's all come down then I hope we'll get
a good agreement let's talk about the
legal aspect of these things another
thing that's emerging this report is
that he's recommended that judges should
now authorized in to intercept
communications such as listening to
phone calls or accessing emails instead
of the home secretary or a senior
politician does that though call into
question the duty that politicians have
which is to deliver national security
and the responsibilities that judges
have yes this needs a lot of care or
what David Anderson has said is that if
you want a system which is clear in
European law international human rights
law then it would be a good thing to be
able to say an independent judge has
approved it the other side of the
argument which he also recognizes is you
can't really have a situation where a
judge can quite lawfully authorized a
very sensitive intelligence operation
overseas where if it goes wrong all the
risk the political risk falls on a Home
Secretary who didn't have a say in
whether the operation took place so
somehow a scheme has got to be devised
that perhaps has both at the moment
judges are involved but they're involved
after the event Pat what David Anderson
has hinted at and I'm not sure how this
would exactly work is that where it's a
national security issue the Secretary of
State the Foreign Secretary for example
would authorize the necessity of the
activity and then a judge would conduct
a review just to check on its lawfulness
and check that it was a reasonable
decision and all necessary information
was available now maybe you could make a
system like that work but you don't want
to make it so complicated little slow
that actually gets in the way of
operational business okay so David
Oman's thank you thank you